foreign
these nasty little blood suckers have
sunk their razor-sharp mouths into you
for the last time
today we're killing every tick on Earth
but how would you trap them
why would we have to modify their DNA
and how could this destroy whole
ecosystems this is what if and here's
what would happen if we killed all ticks
these parasites are nearly
indestructible they can live underwater
for three days and even survive
prolonged periods of drought and they
can go without a blood meal for up to
two years yeah uh killing them won't be
as easy as you might have thought if you
want to take out all ticks you'll have
to have the patience of a tick what does
that mean well they prefer to lie and
wait on Blades of grass preparing for
that perfect moment to strike when a
host walks past they latch on and sink
those Barbed mouths into a thin piece of
skin but if we squished every tick out
of existence what would happen to the
food chain all right tuck your pants
into your socks and get your gloves it's
time to get to work so how are we going
to get rid of every tick
right now people use a pesticide called
Permethrin to kill these tiny arachnids
but blanketing the world with pesticides
would be dangerous for Humanity these
poisons could destroy your liver and
irritate your nose and lungs
yeah all right so what else is on the
table well ticks are attracted to carbon
dioxide you could place dry ice in a
bucket with a strip of masking tape
around the edge
keep the sticky side of the tape up as
the carbon dioxide draws them in they'll
get stuck making it easy for you to end
their lives
but that will only work for a few hours
no if you want them gone for good you'll
have to think on a microscopic level
scientists developed genetically
modified mosquitoes in the Florida Keys
to curb the natural mosquito population
yeah the modified mosquitoes passed on
their mutated genes to the next
Generations eventually killing them off
maybe Frank and ticks aren't the most
ethical solution
what if we got other animals to do our
dirty work for us
we could release natural Predators like
guinea fowl and chickens into infested
areas to Feast on the ticks
but they can only eat so many at a time
and eventually these animals could
become new hosts
but if we did manage to kill off every
tick on the planet
it could positively affect Public Health
you see some ticks can carry Lyme
disease a condition that can cause nerve
damage facial paralysis and brain
swelling
a 2022 study stated that 14 of the
global population has been infected with
it thanks to ticks
wiping out ticks could help prevent the
spread of this disease but this could
end up doing more harm than good
You See ticks are a disease Vector an
organism that carries bacteria and
deadly pathogens that are spread to
other organisms
and without ticks helping control
populations
ecosystems could be overrun with animals
all competing for the same dwindling
resources
no ticks would also mean that reptiles
amphibians and birds would have less to
eat
and this could have a domino effect that
might spell the end of entire habitats
food chains could be disrupted across
the planet and over time we would
witness mass extinctions of plant and
animal species
so as annoying and devastating as they
are we
ticks around
but what if evolution took a turn for
the worse and ticks became the size of
humans
well find somewhere safe to hide and
keep watching because that's a story
for another
[Music]